welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farren cousins i've been sitting in
for david pakman and if you want more
from me you can find me on youtube at
youtube.com the ring of fire i'm also at
youtube.com
farron balanced
let's get back into more of today's
stories before we wrap up today's show
now
donald trump has been out there publicly
blaming kevin mccarthy house minority
leader for even allowing these gosh darn
hearings to happen in the first place
and according to reports coming out
thursday it's actually steve bannon who
has been whispering into trump's ear
that kevin mccarthy is the blame for all
of
this and as trump this week has
continued to blast mccarthy in
statements
and posts on his truth social
something rather extraordinary has
actually happened in the house of
representatives on the republican side
suddenly
you have all of these pro-trump
republicans
that have been coming out
and defending
kevin mccarthy
now before i get into their defenses
let's just mention real quick one of
donald trump's biggest gripes of course
is that kevin mccarthy allowed this to
happen he doesn't have any republicans
on the committee he's screwed up all of
this is a farce and it's all kevin
mccarthy's fault so let me read some
statements
first one is from representative kelly
armstrong of north dakota who says kevin
made the only decision he could
what are we going to do allow them to
just functionally silence entire
constituencies we don't get good hands
all the time in the minority
then jim jordan
who of course has actually been
implicated in the scandal jim jordan
kicked off the committee by nancy pelosi
and obviously for very good reason
jim jordan says
let's say kevin says i'm going to give
you new names there would have been a
problem there i think she was always
going to wind up here because she wanted
the partisan show
okay
what about representative elise stefanik
what does she have to say well she says
i do think kevin has handled this
appropriately and the members support
how we've handled this
yikes
now typically when donald trump comes
out and attacks somebody
the rest of the republican party falls
in line and they say yeah this guy's
terrible
you know we don't like this woman either
whoever it is he's attacking they're
going to go after him
but when you have people who of course
are actually vying for kevin mccarthy's
spot
as potentially the next speaker of the
house people like stefanik people like
jim jordan who would love nothing more
than to be speaker of the house they're
coming out and defending him against the
attacks being leveled at him by donald
trump
that's a problem for trump
it absolutely is
your support
among the house is clearly not as strong
as you thought it was
and that's never a good thing for
somebody in a position like trump is in
to have to find out the hard way
now of course
it could all be for show
republicans right now have to basically
put out this united front they're
getting lambasted by this committee the
whole party looks terrible
so maybe they're just trying to put on a
brave face and try to stick together as
long as they have to and then after that
they're going to eat each other again
but
publicly coming out and refuting
what your big guy has to say
it's not a good look and i don't know
that trump's going to be happy about it